jusqu'à la fin de la semaine se joue
avec 200 compétiteurs le 3e Festival
International d'échec de tour un sport
en grande partie masculin puisqu'en
France seulement 25 % des pratiquants
sont des femmes pour inverser la
tendance demain à l'hôtel de ville de
tour la championne d'échec Tatiana
dbouche donnera une mastercl et ce soir
Marie Sebag multiples championne de
France et d'Europe et première femme
grand maître international d'échec
affrontera simultanément 30 concurrents
un aperçu de l'ambiance avec Clémence
doque parmi les 190 participants du
tournoi toutes les générations sont
présentes mais quand il s'agit de joueus
leur représentativité laisse à désirer
les femmes ne sont socialement pas
encouragées à pousser la porte des clubs
d'échec quant aux joueuses évoluant dans
le milieu elles sont confrontées au
sexisme de leur père masculin par
exemple arbitré au championnat de France
et il y a une jeune femme qui est venu
me voir qui m'a dit que son adversaire
l'a reluqué il a eu des commentaires
dépl
j'ai transmis ça à l'arbitre en chef et
puis commission de discipline et le
joueur exclu du tournoi donc il y a des
choses qui se font ça va dans ce sens-là
mais c'est l améliorer l'accueil des
féminines être intransigeent sur les
comportements misogynes tel est le
devoir des associations et de la
Fédération la médiatisation d'une lettre
ouverte à l'été 2023 a poussé les clubs
à serrer laav il y a d'ailleurs un
groupe de féminine des des échecs qui
s'étaient emparé de du sujet si je puis
dire et qui avait fait une lettre
ouverte au niveau de la fédération pour
se plaindre de de très mauvais
comportements masculins alors qui sont
pas du tout généralisés hein mais il
suffit d'un quoi pour effectivement
poser des problèmes qui peuvent être
sérieux une grand MTE internationale est
à l'honneur de cette édition une réponse
au besoins de modèles féminin dans la
discipline on peut s'identifier essayer
de faire des parties comme elle de de
prendre les mêmes ouvertures d'avoir les
mêmes style de jeu de se dire ah tiens
moi j'étais pareil voilà de d'avoir des
modèles féminins c'est c'est important
aussi parce qu'on s'identifie plus
facilement la nouvelle génération plus
engagée dans la lutte contre les
discriminations compbient prendre le
relais afin de faire des échecs une
discipline plus inclusive pour les
joueuses de
demain